Hey yeah again thank you for probably
skipping lunch because that was what I
had to do after I saw the queue but yeah
we're deaf fest so let's do this
properly with as Evoluzione hello I said
my name is Sebastian I do work for
Deutsche Telekom and basically work on
their smart home platform for the past
seven years now so many started with
developing web front-ends and then added
some note services and Python stuff etc
if you have any questions because I
probably need to leave quite early today
because parent duties I'm ask you disco
on Twitter and the code will be later
published on Oscar disco my username on
github as well so you can totally come
approach me after my talk and ask
questions but if you do not want to for
some reason or you can't just well give
me a ping on Twitter so yeah I said I've
been tinkering with hardware since about
2011 so that was when I started in that
smart home project at Deutsche Telekom
but aside from doing this professionally
I kind of like developed a habit of
trying to connect everything I can get
my hands on so that I can steer it from
a computer or a smartphone I mostly do
this by using an Raspberry Pi or an
Arduino and you should prob'ly know I
have absolutely no background in
electrical engineering I probably you
see that and quite some of the pictures
but also the thing is I don't need to I
don't need to have a background in
technical engineering because well
nearly everything nowadays is connected
via USB maybe like adaptors for wireless
networks like Bluetooth for ZigBee I
don't know mobile phones of course and
yeah even some interesting stuff like
those used be rocket launchers so yeah
there
for as everything can be connected why
use B we're going to talk about use B
today the Universal Serial bus before we
get our hands dirty with some real word
devices and some codes let's talk a bit
about use B basics a little bit about
history so it all started back in 1994 a
few companies they wanted to well
basically end or adapter madness if you
I don't know if you did computer stuff
back then but maybe you remember you had
to plug in keyboards and mice yrp is two
parts you had to connect external drives
via SCSI you had printers connected by a
parallel ports basically everything else
connected via a serial port so to bring
all this madness to an end a group of
engineers led by Intel or led by an
engineer from Intel started developing
news be like one bus system to rule them
all and in late 95 we saw the result of
their efforts
so the first used B devices and host
systems became available but they
weren't really popular back then so not
really welcomed by the users in 1998
Apple decided to be the brave ones they
shipped the computer without a floppy
disk drive and more important without
any serial or parallel ports that was
the iMac g3 and yeah it only had used B
to connect things so that was kind of
like really kick starting that USB
movement in 2000 and is with the
slowness of use B were resolved and D
use B to Panos at Apollo's back got
introduced as well as the first
integrated USB storage device which was
a huge stick with a capacity of 8
megabyte and well for many years after
that I think use B was associated with
like shovelling data into some stick you
can bring to your friends sharing photos
or music I think that was what use B was
associated with like for
time the latest major addition to the
SPAC came in 2008 making us be even
faster and as you see Muse B is quite an
old technology already so when we're
going to talk about api's and control
methods and how to well talk to those
things everything will not be very web
ish it will be like different from the
things that we used to know will be it
will look a bit alien to us as web
developers or as like same modern
software developers because nothing was
designed in the USB world with the web
in mind so yeah you might also probably
think that the electrical engineering
behind such a complex bus system like
USB must be extremely complicated but to
be honest that isn't so this is a
picture of USB 2.0
plaque Tybee mail there I don't know
quadrillions of different views be
plucks out there but I chose this one
because you can see the layout quite
well so we only have four pins here and
four cables in the wire so let's switch
to the schematics to explain that
further so one wire one pin is used to
power the thing it can take up to five
volts of power to of those pins and
wires are used to well
transferring data at first I thought
yeah probably would make sense to have
like one wire for the outgoing data and
one for the incoming data but well
that's wrong they're both basically
transmit the same data in both
directions at the same time providing
some hardware based security and
transport safety mechanism which is like
really an genius thing to do especially
back in the 90s well then of course we
also have to ground pin because we deal
with electrical current
when when use be was introduced it was
introduced as plug-and-play you probably
probably remember that Microsoft keynote
where Bill Gates plucked and that USB
thing and the blue screen appeared yeah
so the thing is use be is well
advertised is plug and play but it often
doesn't live up to the claim I mean
after you bought a device let's say
printer because that happened to me
lately it looks like this no you go on
and search the internet for driver you
insert some kind of native application
you don't even know if you will need it
if that's needed for the device to work
well and then it doesn't work and you
question yourself
oh is that device actually supported on
my operating system but then you
discover that you downloaded the driver
for Mac OS 10 11 but you're running Mac
OS 10 12 now and yeah then you finally
start to install that thing and some
some scary us OS pop-up comes up and
says well you could damage your computer
it could lead to malfunction you're
responsible on your own with there's we
don't take any responsibility well then
actually may be a proper malfunction
kills your existing setup and you're not
able to print on any printer anymore and
then you try to get rid of all that code
and all this stuff you installed but it
kind of sticks around forever it's just
like deep installed in some deeply
hidden directories and your computer and
we're very very hard to get rid of so
what about wow I mean would that be a
way that like the technology use B could
live up to that kind of plug-and-play
and I thought maybe maybe it could look
something like this I mean you buy a
device plug it in we live not in 1994 we
live in modern times so maybe a
notification appears like you're used
from your smartphone like you used you
from your smartphone and yeah you just
then click on it that opens a website
now you're kind of fun because
everything works and basically all you
need to do was five
and the device and click on a link that
automatically magically appeared Wow the
cool right the chrome team thought so as
well so that's why they created web use
be a web standard that enables us to
talk to use B devices directly from the
browser directly from JavaScript running
in our host system VFX so web use beep
is like all the modern and you platform
features only available via HTTP this
for security reasons and like nearly
everything every feature we get on a web
platform nowadays only works by HTTP and
I think that's a that's a good thing
there's no native code of any sort
needed so no need to answer install any
application on e to install any drivers
it just works because the drivers in
your browser and well said it's like
we're plug-and-play you plug in a device
click a link and just use it
I mean University style location that
was some kind of like university ish
style lectures now so well let's better
get to the meat and let's take a look at
the code so when we want to connect to
device from the browser with web use
beam we first well need to connect to
its so-called device descriptor there is
typically only one device descriptor per
device and it provides product
information like vendor ID and some
other informations and also it allows us
to evaluate how many configuration
descriptors we'll get her in a second
we'll be needed in order to do this we
just need to use the Navigator Goosby
request device method we can apply some
filters because otherwise you will see
later there will be some pop up in your
browser that will display use B devices
to connect to and for well user
experience reasons we want to limited
that to devices that we want to connect
to
well none and yet we just need to call
the device open method or the open
method on the API which then in the
background simply runs all the platform
specific steps to start a session
whoever USB device and yeah I've already
mentioned config descriptors so
theoretically a device can have many of
them but usually only what only has one
and this is due to the fact that like in
the early days the standard Windows use
B driver could only handle one
configuration descriptor and
configuration descriptors are there to
measure the amount of power needed for
the device it will also determine
subsequent descriptors for interfaces
and one thing that's very important is
only one configuration can be used at a
time so that is all a bit abstract so
one example from the web board would be
you could implement API versioning with
those config descriptors as you do have
REST API so you say you have a different
after firmware updates you have another
configuration descriptor you could
connect to and that could present a
totally different API or protocol for
the device without breaking the old one
so this is one thing that could be used
for and in JavaScript we used select
configuration method to actually select
off the configurator the config
descriptor so next thing is we need to
select and claim an interface and again
like with the conflict descriptors
theoretically I a conflict descriptor
can have many interface descriptors so
interface descriptors will basically
guides the endpoint descriptors and
carrying out specific device commands
with multiple interfaces working at once
so simple example if you have one of
these multi-purpose devices like a
printer that is also a scanner you could
use one interface or usually it will use
one interface for the printing
functionality
and a different interface for the
scanning functionality so you basically
just choose the features you want to use
and in JavaScript you can use to claim
interface method with a numeric value in
order to do so by adding close to having
this all sorted out so the next thing
after we clamp the interface we are
ready to talk to the endpoint
descriptors and the endpoint descriptors
will identified identified details like
data transfer direction Pauling and also
the types of transfer and often you see
that one endpoint is used for sending
data out one is used for transferring
data in etc but as with all the other
descriptors an interface can have as
many el endpoint descriptors as it likes
I mean there is some theoretical
boundary probably 127 inch but I'm not
sure so none of the devices I have a
tied with reach that number reach the
limit so now that we've to establish the
connection to a specific endpoint on a
device we have three different ways in
which we could communicate with it so
they all come in pairs so one more
method for sending data and one method
for receiving or reading data and we'll
start with the interrupt transfers so
interrupt transfers are typically like
non-periodic small and device initiated
communication that requires some kind of
specific abounded latency so in order to
use them we need to specify the endpoint
number for reading and for writing as
well and well for writing data we just
then need to have some data which mostly
is an array buffer because it's our
binary here and for reading we need to
specify a length so the number of bytes
we want to read from the device in this
case eight bytes so this is like in one
go what the late
data that is present at a device we're
gonna fetch at the latest eight bytes
and then we have control transfers and
those are especially nice for like small
configuration commands because they have
bus priority and they have a
well-defined structure
so think about steering signals like
when you have a robot arm you would
probably use a control transfer to move
that arm up down left left left and send
those commands over the wire they do
require a bit of configuration though
but don't worry about that yet so we'll
tackle those later when we have a
real-world example at hand and the last
type is so called isochronous transfer
and those are actually very rarely used
and mostly I used for audio and video
devices because that can send a
persistent stream of data they do it
lossless so if you if they skip a few
bytes when transferring in incoming
audio nobody doesn't really care
fingers they're so rarely used we won't
use them in our examples and I must
admit I haven't seen them in the wild
yet I haven't tinkered with cameras and
microphones yet because that's a part of
what USB but aside from that I've never
encountered these so please just know
that they're there if you encounter them
sometime in the future so as you see I
brought a few devices with me and I've
done hardware demos in the past and I
have four demos and I'm pretty sure that
at least one will break so now it's time
to place your bets
which one yeah but let's see what we can
do with that devices and let's start out
with the tinkerers favorites the darling
device the Arduino I've worked with the
Arduino in the past years quite a lot
and when I use the Arduino and together
with no chairs I use the library called
johnny-five
johnny-five is also around since 2011
and it's just a wonderful and easy
interface with lots of examples on how
to wire things up I mean you can
basically use just start programming
your outer you know right away with no
jazz and I kind of like ask myself the
question as Johnny 5 is already
JavaScript code maybe we could use that
in the browser as well so demo time now
it gets interesting and now we should
probably Mara to this place good oh
that's a later one so what I'm going to
do now is I'm going to plug in that our
you know I brought with me and you see
that notification up here this is
because the Arduino has some firmware as
is that is web use be compatible and
when I click on that notification after
plugged into device I should end up at a
web address with well controls for my
Arduino so first of all I need to
connect to the device which I have
already done it is already connected and
well I've set myself the task to make
johnny-five running in a browser and
doing so in an interactive console so as
I've seen I've just parked in the
Arduino and now I can basically just
start programming right away with
johnny-five
so i instantiate the LED example and the
first thing I will do is I think I will
just turn it off which well should work
but doesn't yeah great as I said
hardware demos right that's quite some
fun let's see if there is a typo and of
course there's a typo because I forgot
to initiate it so now the LED is
actually turned off I can also I mean
Pro
we see better if I do that I can also
turn it on again and well I can
basically use all the methods from
johnny-five so also the blink method
water then just yeah point the LED so
there are many API examples and the LED
is just like the well tiniest device you
can steer with johnny-five you have like
all the way like basically all the
sensors displays everything at hand and
you can just program them by plugging
them into computer and opening up a web
page which i think is really cool so
back to the presentation no I won't
start iTunes sorry and I don't want to
do dad I want to go back to my displays
that are in sync off okay
here we go again so you might wonder
okay was it hard Sebastian was it hard
to like enable the Arduino to be
controlled from the browser and thanks
to browserify which uses not modules and
is able to swap out some no jest
dependencies and no jazz only modules
for browser modules the browser
counterparts it was actually not that
hard at all so I'm using a fork of the
browser serial port library which was
originally implemented for Chrome
application Chrome apps but there is a
[ __ ] of it which well exposes the serial
part like the low-level serial pod
interface via Web USB and after I
swapped that dependencies
I was basically ready to go but I think
the serial port is a great example to
talk about the different configurations
of the control transfers because this
way you're basically opening up serial
port communication so I think that's a
good example so first of all we're
starting with the witch
so which type of command we're sending
so use be has a couple of standard
commands and command types like class
we're using here that enable hardware to
determine what it should well do ever
data so for example if we supply that
request type of class and have device
that adheres to some kind of standard
like printers do or card readers or
serial port devices but kind of like
ready to use it out of the box I mean
you have other values like vendor which
then would be totally vendor specific
stuff and you would read up their docks
if they have any to do proper
implementation but yeah then we have to
tell our web use be with whom we're
going to talk and we're going to talk
him to internet interface note I mean it
could be an aunt point node as well but
we need to talk to the interface node in
this example then we have to well tell
the device what we want to do send a
command invoke a command and this one is
just please open up the serial port
communication so that's usually
represented by some hexadecimal numbers
we can also send the value of it and
well if we go back to our example with
the moving robot arm we could basically
use that value and a control transfer if
we have a device that speaks to protocol
we have defined to well determine if we
go up left down right so send some
configuration some value with our
request and in the end we have like the
whom again the index so which interface
note we're going to talk to in this case
its interface to so a bit of
configuration needed but it's quite easy
I'd say to figure this out if you have
device especially if the device has a
proper specification or there's some
code written and other languages for
that device as well well then yeah
basically we had note code running in a
browser we were able to well work with
the device in a browser as it would be
from know jazz and I think that's cool
because there's
nothing scary about that it removes all
the scary parts of setting up an
environment because all you need to do
is to connect the device and all the
hard setup steps are just gone
so next demo this is actually a one that
well fails most of the time so I have
some really cheap Android tablet with me
here and wonderful Android sound yeah I
must say I'm an iOS person sorry and
what we're going to do now is first of
all we're going to take a picture of the
audience which is kind of hard because
we have some flashy lights Birds
oh well it would work so great now this
guy took a picture from us you might
think what is he up to
look what I'm actually up to is I want
to connect to that Android device with
web USB and access it via the androids
debugging bridge ADB well let's see if
that works
let's go back to a browser and wow I
should keep that displacing open-sink
the monitors again and open up a browser
and that one should be running on
localhost a - okay so do it that way
that is the beautiful picture I took
just a minute ago you are as even more
you probably won't see much now but
let's let's fix that maybe there's a way
to transfer the picture to our browser
and display it on a big screen well
first thing you have to do is connect to
the device that is my unread device all
right then it asked me if I want to
activate the debugging and of
yes I'll do next thing I'm going to do
is list the files in the storage for the
camera and this should be the picture
that I've just taken so next thing I'll
do is a press download and see if I can
actually download this picture to my
browser and yeah here we go
however the picture because of the
lights but this was basically the
picture I've just taken with this tablet
before I connected it to my browser
there's no server-side code involved
everything runs in the browser I've just
activated the debugging mode and
connected to it so let's go back to a
presentation and see how I did that well
I said I've used the Android debug
bridge the ADB tools so ADB is a defined
protocol you can read all of that sub up
and then you could well it's basically
just a matter of taking that
specification and turning it into code
I'm a submit there is some complexity to
this protocol and we don't have time to
dive deeper into that but well this just
simply roughly illustrates how you would
construct a message that could send over
the wire
well if you don't want to go down that
rabbit hole and implement ADB yourself
well consider yourself lucky because a
few people or some people from Google
already build a library for this which
is called web ad bjs and it makes
accessing those Android devices as easy
as doing this I mean with that library
we basically can do anything that
regular ADB allows us to you as well so
we can we can have full UNIX shell
access from the browser on the Android
device we can upload apks we can as
we've seen access all the user data a
whole file system and that should ring
about because wait access or the user
data upload apks haven't those people
well thought about security when they
came up with Web USB well I mean of
course they did so as you've seen if you
want to connect to your device you can
only do that when invoked by user
gesture so you always need to have a
pointer Mouse some event you trigger ask
the user to open up that connection
dialog there is no other way there's no
programmatic way to invoke that and then
you have to explicitly grant permission
by choosing the device and clicking okay
to connect it also you've abused beat us
back doesn't allow to interfere with
cameras microphones or USB mass storage
devices directly so Dallas just simply
not possible and as I've learned from
Niels who is going up who's going to be
the next speaker and talks about where
Bluetooth and a podcast he's done
apparently there is a kill switch in
chrome that the chrome team can flip
over if while some big security issue of
vulnerability is discovered as they did
like roughly a year ago with the Yubikey
to two-factor authentication use B
devices because you apparently were able
to read out I think the keys that were
stored in that device via Web USB and
kind of like defeat the whole purpose of
that two-factor authentication device
and what happened then was that someone
from Google at a chrome team kind of
like flipped the switch and disabled web
users been all of the browser's out
there so no web use be anymore
until they fix it with the next browser
revision but yeah apparently there is a
thing you can well have mixed feelings
about that but in the end it's a good
thing because it's about and user
security going on with the demos so as I
do work professionally in the sector of
IT in smart home of course I well
brought some smart home devices with me
well tiny ones I'd say
everything enough right good so I want
to connect devices that use two
different wireless protocols together
using web USB so I have to be more
precise I have this light switch here
that you can glue on your wall which is
just a simple light switch that is
connected by the EnOcean protocol
interestingly the company behind an
ocean without suspect is quite close and
quite close to Munich so quite close to
here and that is just an very
well-defined protocol for connecting
wireless IOT or smart home devices and
you could use development donald's like
this to well have a bridge from usb to
that vilas protocol and then I'm going
to use that light switch to turn on and
off Bluetooth bulb
well the Bluetooth bulb is connected
where the web Bluetooth standard which
well if you're interested in that you
should stay definitely stay for the next
talk I'm not going into details about
that all right so first time's a charm
demo time again so here we go let's just
see if we have used to light up and
first of all I need to connect to my use
be an ocean dongle okay
get that then I need to connect to UD
light up oh hi yeah thanks just yeah I
was kind of like afraid that I will
forget that every time to sync the
screens again but yeah here we go
so there's the light bulb I've connected
everything and let's see if I can flip
that switch and turn it off
Wow kind of like it receives the signals
and here we go
now it's off
I can do it again turn it on turn it off
it just well it just seems like take
some time to transmit the signals but
generally it's working so I hit the
switch and it will just take some time
or doesn't work at all sometimes well
that you've seen it worked a couple of
times I must admit I haven't implemented
the whole and ocean protocol just the
parts I thought I need and now maybe
maybe some parts I kind of need I forgot
so one more chance you also need to have
quite have a distance to that download
but not that far and also not too close
apparently yeah well I'll say something
broke but in the end it worked at least
two or three times
still as great great outcome yeah so a
lot of monitors switching today but here
we go
so connecting to that USB stick was
quite easy because it supports the
serial port protocol and basically I've
already had all that connecting to
serial port code from the Arduino
example which uses that as well at least
johnny-five uses that in the background
as well and then it was like all a
matter of taking the data and well
encoding that data to be a string and I
mean the problem with you notion
protocol I mean it's it's extremely well
designed so there was that light switch
fee it has no battery all the power that
it needs for transmitting the signal is
generated by the kinetic well press of
their button unfortunately and
fortunately for me the power that is
generated by this kinetic press isn't
enough for any well let's say
cryptographic up cryptographic things so
well all this that goes over the air is
just plain text or plain binary and
and all I need to figure out which
button of that switch has been pressed
was like parse out a specific part of
that substring that I encoded so that
was fairly easy one thing as use B as
said wasn't mentioned with it wasn't
designed with the weapon mind it doesn't
have any event handler mechanism or such
by itself so instead we kind of like
need to build one on around and this is
an example of a simple like read loop
that just goes on and on I think
Stephanie just also showed that with her
connected clothes example so it just
constantly reads data from one endpoint
of the device and emits the data and
then it calls herself again so it's just
just going over going over reading data
until there's some error like removing a
device would trigger an error because it
can't read then from it anymore and then
it just stops so this is like a very
very simple way of data pooling from usb
and basically nearly everyone who works
with USB devices seems to do that okay
last demo this will involve quite a few
devices we've only tinkered with like
one or two there's actually we'll
connect three devices because we're
going to build a public library a public
library checkout system using RFID cards
a barcode scanner and a receipt printer
so I just need to just plug in some of
the devices and it's like I would have
loved that stuff as a kid
I mean having this stuff you only know
from shops it's like just pretty cool
it's actually quite cheap to get on eBay
I think the printer and everything also
makes wonderful noises was just like
print I was like 15 euros that thing the
barcode scanner was 10 euros so it was
just really cool and really cheap to
start playing with it
so it's switching monitors in Sinking
monitors time again and let's head on to
our last example okay so let's connect
oh maybe I should also plug in the
printer because otherwise I can't
connect to it here we go
that's really a simple standard printer
and the first thing we need to do is we
need to identify and I should really
mark those cards because well okay that
wasn't the right one maybe that was yeah
that was the right I referred Iike great
so now I've affected cated at my library
my tiny library and next thing I'll do
is I can read out the barcodes from
those books this is one of my favorite
book javascript the definite guide the
edition from 2002
it covers JavaScript version 1.5
definitely something you should read so
let me see okay I just scanned it and it
should show up here oh yeah there we
have it maybe it's also because of my
slow internet connection because I've
hooked it up to an online API which
takes the ISBN number I'm reading from
the barcode and turns it into actual
informations about the book so another
book I really like as secrets of the
JavaScript ninja so I want to have that
as well and here we go so great I think
those two books are enough let's just
print my receipt and great here we go
my tiny public at hoc library works as
expected
fortunately great and there's no more
money to flipping and I'll be done in a
sec great
so yeah printer connected to the printer
was actually quite easy because that
adheres to standard and I not only need
to encode all the text after I connected
to it use transfer out on the right end
point and it just instantly prints yes I
was really like surprised with that the
other two device said it was a bit
harder because they belong to a special
group of devices human interface devices
or short hid our keyboards and pointer
devices belong to this group as well as
many older devices who only need to
transfer numbers and text like the
barcode scanner or the RFID reader so
hid devices will not be part of the verb
USB SPAC part of the API they'll use a
new one which might look like this but
as of today no browser implemented it
but the chrome team is working on making
that API reality so urea tea is just
like as those are just keyboard devices
emulating keyboards you kind of like
need to do this ugly thing and you
should never put that into production at
least you know what you're really doing
so basically just scanning for all the
key presses at with a global handler and
then what just trying to decide from
which device everything came but yeah
generally demos kind of worked well
little bit relieved to be honest and if
you want to start with tinker with web
use bean USB devices check out the - -
device lock chrome developer feature
because you can see all the devices
including the events bendin product ID
is also Bluetooth devices not only use B
devices you're [ __ ] in if you don't
have a device I want to test your codes
you can use go to use be internals and
basically generate some bogus devices
that are can be used for testing only
and sadly we only have web use bein
chrome and other vendors already
expressed that they're not so fond of
the spec and well mostly because
security concerns but the thing is I
think one browser is already enough for
our specific use cases there's also an
NPM package called node web use B which
allows you to use the web use B API from
with a note so effectively turning web
use B into across platforms back few
things you should take away so web use B
lets you browser developers write your
own drivers for devices as we've seen we
can build plug-and-play systems like a
check out system for shops no need for
extra software no need to install
software you can use an Android tablet
and hook app to use B devices and it
just works
instant sharp check out system may be
connected to warehouse management system
it makes super easy to start tinkering
with hardware like think about schools
or in the coderdojo so no hard setup
steps for beginners we just plugin
devices and play with them like with the
arduino i wish we had that when a lot of
kids in the coderdojo in the past years
just showed up with android tablets and
I wanted to start work with Harbor and
program hardware but with just an
Android tablet it's kind of hard we can
write drivers that work there are truly
isomorphic that work in the backend
systems as well as on our front end
systems and Wow the most important thing
is they're kind of like we're improving
lives of the end-user bringing USB to
that state of plug-and-play and always
should have been and as developers of
course because just have lots of fun
build shitty robots and stuff which is
the most really truly most important
thing having fun so yeah thank you very
much and questions later
I'll be outside after I enjoyed needs
talk thank you
you